the jurogan experience was amanda nunez
your your most difficult fights
uh
i never was considered like a
difficulty of the fight
only for the fight
for this five rounds or less uh for me
difficulty of the fight it's
combination of training camp your
approach to the fight
fight week
and the fight itself so uh
i still cannot like um
answer this question i think it's the
hardest question
and uh every time people ask me like
what is your hardest fight hardest
opponent and i just cannot answer
because it's so different each fight
it's a different approach different
training camp everyone is difficult
difficult with their like own style
something like that
uh that's why
hard to say hi what is difficult about
amanda style
your sizes
size it's not her style it's not her
style it's just she's big and heavy
yeah and power
uh everyone has power
everyone has power one if you're
speaking about 135
weight class every everyone has like a
lot of power but yeah amanda i think
she's just like big than anyone bigger
you think she's bigger than the rest of
the division what's she's walk weight uh
what is her working weight 160 170 i
don't know is it really that bad i don't
know well she does fight at 145 and she
looks the same at 145 as she does at 135
and obviously at 145 she's able to knock
out cyborg
yeah yeah it's kind of like you know
what about zen accounts
everyone has
like chances
to knock out each other so it's just
like it's it's 50 50. it's the situation
if
for example
you have interchange
the chances are more for each one right
but you have to smart to have you have
to fight very smart you know that small
gloves it's like more possibility to be
knocked out or you make the knockout so
if um
it's kind of like or you or you're gonna
hit or
they're gonna hit you so it's kind of
like this is what i saw in their fights
so it was interchange and this
interchange who's on that moment were
more lucky
if you had
a long time out like if the ufc said uh
here we are
it's uh we are in uh october if they
said uh valentina august
next year
we would like you to fight amanda nunez
that's going to be this big super fight
would you try to gain weight would you
lift weights would you do anything
differently or would you just
concentrate on technique and strategy
and maintain the same weight you're at
now we are october and august yeah do
you know anything they can approach me
with this i'm gonna try
well i think
when i look at the two of you it's the
most compelling fight in in the ufc in
women's mma i believe that's the most
compelling fight is because you're both
at the top of your game and you there's
an argument for both of you to be the
greatest of all time
i'm not gonna
do anything special to lift up my weight
you wouldn't start working out and lift
weights no no no no because um
i don't believe it's gonna help
i believe it's gonna
be worse for the fighter because if in
your whole life you was like a
certain body type
you know how to carry like certain
muscles amount of muscles and then
suddenly for last two three months you
start to carry way more so what's gonna
happen you're gonna be slower
you're not gonna have same uh resistance
for the whole fight because you have to
carry more
weight on top of you so i
will do the same
i just want to do the last like last day
rate cut for what i do for 125. i gonna
lose i'm not gonna lose this six
pound what is like um
and i just
will eat normally as i do and train the
same ways as i do
it's interesting to see different
people's approaches right like uh when
israel adasanya went up to challenge
john bolhovich for the 205 pound title
he did the same thing that you're saying
he didn't gain any weight he just uh
just concentrated on his technique and
training
but there was moments in that fight
where the size of yombohovich
it was evident when in the grappling
exchanges when he was able to control
him on the ground
do you think that there's any benefit i
mean this is why i'm saying if you have
a long time i'm not saying if you just
have a normal eight-week camp i'm saying
if they give you eight months nine
months and they let you know in advance
you still don't think you'd ever try to
gain any weight i don't think it's it's
still gonna help because uh someone
naturally bigger
every time we'll have this advantage
being bigger no matter how more weight
you're gonna put on top you are still
the same just with the extra weight on
yeah
well that's why i'm interested in jon
jones and jon jones when he's trying to
move up to the heavyweight division he's
gained a lot of weight and he wants to
be over the 265 pound limit and then cut
back down to 265.
so i believe he's walking around
somewhere in the 260s now
i think we will know the answer only
when he will fight in this weight class
and we will know exactly how it's gonna
affect him will it be good for him or
bad for him so we don't know as i say
every person is different
and i know how my body works i know what
is good for me what is bad for me israel
he knows exactly the same about his body
type john jones he knows exactly about
himself so this is
everyone's approach and i think everyone
should do
what they think it's gonna help them to
win
so for you
from going down from 135 to 125 was the
right move he felt like much better at
125. it's my natural weight class it's
like it's like what i was competing all
the time have you ever thought of going
lower
115 yeah and
die from the hunger
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify